in many other videos we've taken
equations like this and tried to quote
solve for X what we're going to do in
this video is deepen our understanding a
little bit about what's going on and
really think about the notion of
equivalence or equivalent statements so
let me write that down
equivalence now what do I mean by
equivalence well I'll use this equation
here to essentially keep rewriting it in
equivalent ways and I'll talk a little
bit more about what that means so one
thing that I could do to essentially
write the same equivalent statement is I
could distribute this 3 onto the X and
or onto the X plus 1 and then this part
of it could be re-written as 3x plus 3
and then we have minus X is equal to 9
now what I will say or what it might be
obvious to you on some level is this top
equation and this second equation are
equivalent what does that mean it means
if it if one of them is true for given X
the other one will be true for that same
X as well and vice versa and we can
write other equivalent statements for
example if we were to combine X terms
here if we were to take 3x and then
minus X right over there I could rewrite
that as 2x and then I have plus 3 is
equal to 9 now all three of these
statements are equivalent if there's an
X where 2 times that X plus 3 is equal
to 9 then it is also the case that 3
times that X plus 1 minus X is equal to
9 and vice-versa if there's some X that
would make this top equation true then
it's going to make this last equation
true and we can do other equivalents
preserving operations and you've seen
them before you could subtract 3 from
both sides in general if you are adding
or subtracting the same value from both
sides it is equivalent equivalence
preserving if you are distributing a
value like we didn't in that first step
that is equivalence preserving if you
combine like terms so to speak that is
equivalence preserving
and so here we'll do an equivalence
preserving operation we'll subtract 3
from both sides and you would get 2x is
equal to 6 and once again any X that
satisfies this last equation will
satisfy any of the other equations and
vice versa anything that's any exit
satisfies and if any of these other
equations will satisfy this last one and
so they are all equivalent to each other
and then another equivalence preserving
operation is to multiply or divide both
sides by a non-zero constant and so here
we could divide both sides by 2 2 is not
in 0 and it's constant and if we did
that we will get another equivalent
statement that X is equal to 3 so any X
that satisfies this and there's one x
equals 3 would satisfy the other ones
and any X that satisfies any of the
other ones would satisfy this last one
so these are all equivalent so one way
to think about it adding the same number
to both sides of an equation that is
equivalent preserving multiply or
dividing both sides by a nonzero
constant value is equivalent preserving
distributing like we did in this first
step equivalence preserving combining
like terms equivalence preserving now
you're probably saying well what are
some non equivalence preserving
operations well imagine something like
this let me just start with something
very obvious if I said that X is equal
to 2 a non equivalence preserving
operation is if I were to add or
subtract or multiply or divide only one
side of this equation by a value let's
say I only added one to the left side
then I would have X plus 1 is equal to 2
and it is not the case that anything
that satisfies this second equation
satisfies the top equation or vice versa
x equals 2 clearly satisfies the top
equation but it doesn't satisfy the
second one that's because we did a non
equivalence preserving operation
likewise if I only multiplied the
right-hand side by 3 I would get X is
equal to 6 well by only multiplying the
right-hand side by a value it's not the
case that anything that satisfies x
equals 6 will satisfy
x equals two that is somewhat obvious
here now there's a little bit trickier
city scenarios let's say we have the
equation 5x is equal to 6x
now one temptation is well I want to do
the same thing to both sides I could
just divide both sides by X what will
happen in that scenario well if you
divide both sides by X you could think
that an equivalent statement is that 5
is equal to 6 and you know that there's
no X for which 5 is equal to 6 you can't
make 5 equals 6 or 6 equal 5 and so this
would somehow make you imply that okay
there's no X that can satisfy if you
assume that these were equivalent
statements you'd say there's nothing
that could satisfy 5 equals 6 so maybe
there's nothing that satisfies this top
equation but this actually isn't an
equivalence preserving operation because
you're actually dealing with the
scenario where X is equal to 0 and
you're dividing by 0 and so you have to
be very careful when you're dividing by
a variable especially if the variable
that makes that equation true happens to
be 0 and so in order to be clear that
you do you're preserving equivalence
here the way that I would tackle it is I
would subtract 5x from both sides and if
you do that and that is an equivalence
preserving operation you could subtract
that expression from both sides or that
term from both sides and then you would
be left with 0 is equal to X and now 0
equals x and 5 x equals 6x these are
equivalent statements they are
equivalent equations anything that makes
this one true is going to make that one
true and anyone MIT that makes that one
true is going to make this one true now
one last thing you might have heard me
say you can multiply or divide by a
non-zero value and that's going to be
equivalence preserving and hopefully you
just got a sense of why dividing by 0 is
not a good idea in fact dividing by 0 is
always going to be a strange thing and
it's undefined but also multiplying by 0
for
if I had let's say actually let me start
over here if I had 2x is equal to six
and if I were to multiply both sides by
zero I would get zero is equal to zero
and zero equals to certain zero is true
for any X zero is always going to be
equal to zero but the problem is is that
first statement isn't true for all X
it's only true for x equals three so
these two are not equivalent statements
they have a different set of X's that
will satisfy them and so you have to be
very careful when you're dealing with
things that are either are zero you can
add or subtract zeros obviously that's
not going to change things much but when
you multiply both sides by zero you can
start getting things that are not
equivalent statements and when you
multiply or divide by things that could
be zero like variables that also is a
dangerous game to play